I'd have a long shot of me driving in a
truck and Steven Spielberg would be
sitting down hiding from the camera I
don't know why you just but he got the
biggest kick out of that he gets only
all he will know that I was here
[Music]
Monsters Inc there's a lot of fun I
started doing cartoons when my daughter
was very young and I tried to bring her
up with cartoons like we'd watch
cartoons all the time and I kinda did it
for her when they moved Billy Crystal
into the booth with me when we were
doing it together that the energy just
took off I tried to hang on to whatever
Billy was doing and write it together
with him yeah I've heard two different
approaches to this some guys say it's
real easy and for me I have to put my
whole body into the performance in order
to get the voice pitch to where where I
want it to be and it's a hard day's work
it doesn't sounds easy but it's it's
pretty tiring but it's fun but you have
to do a million takes you know to get
the they don't know what they want yet
so they'll pick it out of whatever you
got yeah I can be a little tyrant but
you don't have to dress up or wear
makeup three stories it's the first lead
I've ever gotten and I was just coming
off of a musical on Broadway and it's a
David Byrne wants to meet with you oh
this is cool
and I'm out with him for a while I
really liked him and I liked what he was
trying to say in the in the film and it
was very gentle and five haven't seen it
for a long time
but I got to sing in 1950 when I was
born
I haven't read this first quite yeah six
feet tall and size 12 shoe approach was
taking what I could get off of the
script and it just seemed to work
everything felt good we shot in Texas
and the people were lovely and everybody
was great yeah it was that was a lot of
fun and idea this is the most time I'd
hit in front of a camera without
loitering racing Arizona while I was
shooting true stories I went and had a
meeting with the Coen brothers
yeah shot that but three months later I
had a great audition with them and we
just wound up goofing around for about
an hour and it was one of those things I
hit so much fun I really didn't care
whether I got the role or not because he
used to a lot of rejection and I always
looked at it Gale Snopes has said you
know being their criminal genius with a
two-digit IQ the whole script was just
beautiful just made me laugh was the
aunt I had a really good film career
going you know nobody knew who I was but
it's perfect because in they'd hire me
because I still worked cheap so I was
doing a lot and I got to the point where
I was tired of living in a suitcase I
went in and then read with Roseanne the
first time and it was as easy as falling
out of bed we just hit it off we laughed
a lot I was well so one of those things
where I didn't think I was going to get
it so I just didn't care I was real
loose and I go this would be nice to
have because I could settle down in one
place for a while and I didn't want to
come to Los Angeles unless I had a job
and it did it just happened their way I
feel there's an ownership about it maybe
too much where he won't go out on a limb
and try something else but he I think
he's a pretty stable guy and I really
admire him when I was drinking I'd love
to sit down and drink with him and I
probably did
a phobia I like working with Frank
Marshall I think this is the first film
he'd ever done and maybe the only film
he's ever done but he was real easy
calling and welcome collaboration I
didn't know exactly what I was going to
do until it was too late to think about
it
and I wound up just doing a biology
slash gym teacher that I had you
probably lost control of all his bodily
functions there's no spider here but I
will hunt down the alleged Arachne and
spritz him to kingdom come
and you wouldn't believe this guy anyway
if you saw him at work it said I kinda
use this and it worked out perfectly I
think and it was a lot of fun because
like I'd have a long shot of me driving
in a truck and Steven Spielberg would be
sitting down hiding from the camera I
don't know why you just but he got the
biggest kick out of that he gets only
all he will know that I was here and I
would I would take to go into Amblin
entertainment a lot after I've got off
for Roseanne and just hanging out and
seeing everybody it was a very friendly
place I had no idea what I was gonna do
- just baffled me and I wanted to reach
for it and do something nice and I think
it holds up no babe that's what I want
to do over started practicing throwing
left handed maybe nine six to nine
months before the picture started and I
got it down all right and I could hit
okay
when we started rolling but we didn't
shoot the baseball scenes for another
month and I lost a lot of what I could
do in their time but I found out he was
a sidearm pitcher I finally saw a film
of him pitching that I didn't know was
around and I think we all could have
known a lot more about baseball in
general before we shot here some hinky
things in it I wish we heard I had more
CGI then because we had pitchers that
couldn't find the plate and they kept
moving them in move it a minute and his
swing was a loop like a fungo bat which
is how we learned how to hit from fungos
at the home for boys and that was a
style and that's he used to loop a lot
to right field
it was like Wrigley Field 100 degrees
wool uniform but I just love the guy so
much you know you know the great man
better pay a toy yeah yeah that's always
been a do over a film of mine I just
wish I could have gotten her right I
could have gotten it better The
Flintstones Rick Moranis was an ace Rick
Moranis is the best
I loved showing up for work with Rick
Moranis
[Music]
yeah they kind of sandbagged me uh
Steven Spielberg cast me in a film
called hallways and I was just in heaven
I did this is the best thing so on the
day of the first table read he goes
ladies gentlemen I like to say something
before we start I found my Fred
Flintstone and it just took the wind out
of me it's not something I was looking
forward to doing it yeah I felt like I
was stand back it was hot it was sweaty
but it was it was fun and I got to meet
Jonathan winters who was in a scene that
was great why I didn't think this was in
the summer of 1990 the writing was just
gorgeous it's a bit more mystical
magical and but yeah I'd love to just
just playing this guy with multiple
identities and he's just sincere as hell
and he loved Barton
all right brother then I trust trust
Yolo Nathan all the way whatever they
say is is good for me
and that the sets were wonderful you can
work on with John Turturro was wonderful
King Ralph I developed a friendship with
Peter O'Toole that lasts to this day
even though he has a bad taste to remain
dead I'd never met anyone like Peter
O'Toole and I don't reckon I ever will
I just love listening to him talk and he
loved talking and he loved telling
stories and he he would take me around
he wasn't drinking at the time and he
would take me around and watch me drink
to various places and to give me a
little history lesson about what we were
into just tell these fabulous stories
and yeah I wanted to be him when I grew
up I just loved Pedro it took just
marvelous and we had to shoot a lot of
scenes in Soho back around Piccadilly
Circus in the West End with no police
security and we were shooting on a
Saturday night and it was just catches
can what I hope we grab this hope we can
get it but yeah that's one I'd like to
go back and do now because I'm too old
but because I know London so much better
and I know the way of the world over
there I mean it was good to play and
honest and like that but I have I wish I
had a little more knowledge
[Music]
it was endless endless kept doing it
again and again and again and I'm you
know like 150 pounds overweight
and sweating battery acid by the end of
the day and it just kept going who is
relentless the big lebowski the Joel and
Nathan movie another role they had be in
mind for we were lucky that we had a
couple of weeks of rehearsal of breeding
the script reading the script reading
the script people of always ask me if we
improvise the dialogue and I couldn't
improvise anything better than Joel and
Ethan the it just sounded like that
because of the the luxury time we had of
rehearsing with it plus a dialogue was
just so damn good that's one of those
things I've always said performed itself
just right off the page yeah yeah I'm
really proud of that film and I got to
work with Jeff who is just one of the
best people I've ever been around I'll
see him every once in a while and it's
always great you did the way talk see
it's like you're the only person in the
room you know one of those guys - then
Cloverfield Lane I'd never play anything
like it before yeah he was pretty bad
they need scared people that's great
please give me one chance
hey Howard just calm down what a chance
to answer with some dignity or I swear
to god you're going into this barrel
while you're alive the field is me I got
to shoot well though in New Orleans and
that was wonderful
Mary Elizabeth was wonderful everybody
was we were in this bunker all the time
and it kind of gets to you after a while
the bunker mentality it was different
and ultimately fun old brother were out
big TNT from oh brother were out was a
psychotic Bible salesman Klansmen he's
got strings all over the south the parts
that I love more was where I was beating
Tim Blake Nelson and George Clooney with
a tree branch and I just laid it upside
the head of Tim Blake Nelson knocked him
out and George looking at me with a
piece of chicken in his mouth he's I
don't think I know what you're getting
at big Dan but yeah it's it's Joel and
Ethan and you fell in love with the
script they surround themselves with a
great crew there was a certain amount of
shorthand that you use when you're with
people that long and again the script is
wonderful flight clueless in your face
self-centered buddy he loved Denzel
character and would have done anything
for him I mean the guy flies a plane how
cool is that it's just the coolest guy
he'd ever seen and he's more than
willing to co-opt in for his own needs
they're saying sweet Jesus what a stud
that pilot is your hero man you will
never pay for another drink as long as
you live I don't know how much of his
own product to use this but I think he's
take it or leave it
for me it was obvious on the page he's
just one of these southern loudmouth
guys you know with a hairdo that's 40
years old and you know flip-flops shorts
he's taking it easy he's kind of a dude
want to be from a while crane Burnett
from Treme was at idealist good marriage
good family and Katrina killed him
Katrina broke him you couldn't believe
all the horror that came out of it all
the ineptitude and evil in the city that
he loved I think he loved New Orleans
above everything it was well written and
it was good I don't think he could have
survived more than one season he's very
sensitive in something in him broke when
the when the levees failed you say why
rebuild it I say [ __ ] you you rebuilt
Chicago after the fire you rebuilt San
Francisco after the earthquake another
one where I got to work at home and it
was very relevant because it broke my
heart when Katrina happened I was
helpless something you loved so much and
you're helpless to do anything it's like
having a loved one with cancer or
something and it came back and it came
back stronger yeah it's actually based
on a man that that did commit suicide
but I think he loved teaching and I
tried to get that I'm we only had I
think one does the day he killed himself
he was teaching a morning class and I
tried to make it very passion and inside
Llewyn Davis
I was interesting to play somebody so
soft absorbed and immobile and addicted
to smack he really style himself
trust well-liked to make a good
appearance crumbling inside and we never
did figure out what what acts he played
I swore he was a piano player I think
Ethan thought he was a trumpeter and
Joel thought he played sax but in jazz
you know we play all of those 12 notes
of the scale
not three chords on a hookah lately we
never never nailed it down but I just
seem like a pianist to me Fargo John
Chambers for Marko was tops in his craft
is a leading makeup man discovered a lot
of tricks and devices and at the same
time was a operative working for the
Central Intelligence Agency super
patriotic not much room for fools
want to set up a production company and
build a cover around making a movie that
we're not gonna make no so you want to
come to Hollywood act like a big shot
yeah without actually doing anything no
go right in and the front of his saw me
after he'd seen the film he goes how did
you get Johnny's limp down that's that
in there Johnny handle wimp I died
that's me
he couldn't believe it it can be
limiting and that you don't want to step
on anybody's toes or offend anybody but
by serving the script and the script was
devoted to the guy once I sat down with
the hallmark and everything else fell
into place there was just a mentor and a
good friend and I idolized him yeah
until I work with him that was all over
the righteous gemstones I've always been
a fan of Danny think he's honest above
everything else and funny but it's the
honesty that portrays he doesn't care if
he comes off looking like a jerk and a
buyer that because it makes them all
appalled a funnier well go on big shot
you got everybody's attention what do
you got to say to me
make it good I got church lunch waiting
he's a gonna call him a successful
businessman now and his life has fallen
apart he's still grieving for his wife
I think it's been over a year since she
died he's got these rotten kids that he
finally got to face up to dealing with
his wife dealt with him all the time and
because he was busy doing something she
was the light of his life when she died
his whole world died so I think he's got
to start snapping out of that put to use
an empty shell and mr. karma started
knocking
the door is he still have to deal with
that but I think he definitely a man of
faith he just got blindsided by how
successful the business came became and
he wants more of it it's like power
corrupts and yeah I was so pleased
ironically it was about a day or two
after I lost the Roseanne job and this
came up and I read it and I liked it as
well
got no reason why let's take a shot at
it ah duh it's in Charleston I love
Charleston people cannot be beat they're
great
there was a great shoot all around